DEPORTATIONS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO WAIT, THE FEDERAL JUDGE HAS
AT LEAST FOUGHT THAT EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND MEANWHILE IT APPEARS
THAT ONE OF HIS OTHER TOP AGENDA
ITEMS WILL BE BLOCKED, THE
DEMOCRATIC CINEMA BOUND TO
UPHOLD ONE PRINCIPLE WHICH WOULD
BE THE LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER IN
REACTION OF ALL THIS, LINDSEY
GRAHAM, SENATOR, I WOULD SAY
WITH TODAY’S VOTE, 45 PEOPLE, IF
THEY THINK IT’S UNCONSTITUTIONAL
TO HAVE A POSTPRESIDENTIAL
IMPEACHMENT, I WOULD SAY THAT
THIS THIS IS DEAD AND UNFINISHED
AND A WASTE OF OUR TIME AND OUR
MONEY.
>> IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND ILL
CONCEIVED.
THE ONE THING THAT WE HAVEN’T
TALKED ABOUT THAT I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
HE WAS IMPEACHED WITHOUT ONE
WITNESS BEING CALLED AND HE DID
NOT HAVE A LAWYER.
SO ONE OF THE REASONS IS BECAUSE
I DON’T WANT TO LEGITIMIZE THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS IN THE
HOUSE.
I THINK IT IS A DANGER TO THE
DEMOCRACY AND SO WHAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN NEXT IS THAT THIS IS
THE FLOOR AND NOT A CEILING IN
THIS CASE, A MOTION TO DISMISS
ON DAY NUMBER ONE, MORE THAN 45
VOTES ONCE WE HEAR ABOUT WHY IT
SHOULD BE DISMISSED AND IF WE
DON’T GIVE 51 WE WILL GO TO
TRIAL AND WE WANT THE AUDIENCE
TO KNOW THAT THEY NEVER CALL THE
WITNESS IN THE HOUSE.
IF THERE IS AN EFFORT BY THE
DEMOCRATS TO CALL A SINGLE
WITNESS IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE, THEY HAVE NO RECORD IN
THE HOUSE, IT WILL BE A
PANDORA’S BOX BEING OPENED, WE
WILL SEE THIS THING GO ON FOR
WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS.
SO I’M HOPING THAT WE HAVE A
STIPULATION OF FACTS AND
WITNESSES AND WE CAN GET THIS
BEFORE WE BEGIN.
>> WHY WOULD THE SENATE -- THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, IT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE MORE SOBER
BODY OF THE TWO, WHY WOULD THEY
LEGITIMIZE AND VALIDATE THIS
SNAP IMPEACHMENT, IT MAKES NO
SENSE TO ME, ALSO WHAT ABOUT ALL
OF THE EVIDENCE IN THE COURT
DOCUMENTS NOW SHOWING THAT THEY
BELIEVE THAT THEY MISSED ALL OF
THE PRE-PLANNING THAT TOOK
PLACE, THAT TOTALLY CONTRADICTS
THE NARRATIVE WHAT HAPPENED AT
THE CAPITAL WAS INCITED BY WORDS
OR PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE WORDS
OR PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTUALLY MEAN
SOMETHING AS WELL, LETTING YOUR
VOICES BE HEARD.
THAT WAS THERE IN THE SPEECH,
THAT IS WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
>> WELL, THE REASON OF THE
EVIDENCE OF INCITEMENT IS THAT
THEY ARE NOT PLAYING ON THE
OTHER NETWORKS.
HE SAW ONE CLIP WHERE SOMEBODY
SAID OKAY, THIS IS THE CRIME.
THE FACT THAT THERE IS NO CLIP
TELLS YOU ALL THAT THERE IS TO
KNOW.
I THINK THAT DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
ARE AFRAID THAT IF THEY DON’T
GIVE SOME CREDIBILITY TO THIS
TRIAL THAT STARTED IN THE HOUSE
THAT THEY ARE IN TROUBLE.
AND JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN PART OF
THIS, NOT ONLY ON POLICY BUT ON
THE IDEA THAT THIS IS THE CASE,
HOW EASY WOULD IT BE FOR JOE
BIDEN TO SAY THAT IT’S BAD TO
IMPEACH A PRESIDENT AFTER THEY
LEAVE OFFICE, ENOUGH ALREADY
WITH DONALD TRUMP, LET’S LOOK
FORWARD.
SO TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT JOE
BIDEN’S ABILITY AND DESIRE BY
THE FACT THAT HE’S SITTING ON
THE SIDELINE AND HIS ONLY
COMMENT HAS BEEN I DON’T THINK
THAT THEY HAVE THE VOTE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO APPLY THE
SAME STANDARDS TO MAXINE WATERS,
THAT I’M GOING TO TAKE DONALD
TRUMP OUT TONIGHT OR THAT THEY
DON’T WANT IT ANYMORE, OR CHUCK
SCHUMER ON THE STEPS OF THE
SUPREME COURT THREATENING
CAVANAUGH OR KAMALA HARRIS AFTER
THE POLICE PRECINCT WAS TURNED
DOWN, SAYING THAT THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO STOP AND THEY SHOULDN’T
STOP AND THEY WON’T STOP,
BEWARE, WE WILL NOT STOP.
WITHOUT PAYING FOR BAIL LIKE SHE
WAS PART OF A GROUP.
>> ACTUALLY TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
OUT OF JAIL AND THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO STOP AND THEY SHOULDN’T
STOP, COMPARE THAT TO A
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IN THE
SPEECH.
I WOULD LIKE TO GET THIS OVER
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU TRY TO CALL
ONE WITNESS, DON’T DO THAT,
LET’S GET THIS TRAVESTY OVER
WITH QUICKLY.
>> I ALWAYS CRITICIZE
REPUBLICANS WHEN THEY LACK
VISION AND THEY DON’T HAVE A
BACKBONE, 45 REPUBLICAN